Antonio vitterino is director general of
iom the International Organization for
migration and he's joining us now from
Geneva thank you very much indeed for
being with us I understand that your
organization regularly sends Aid convoys
across the border into Northern Syria
when you're faced with a situation on
the scale that we've been seeing over
the last few days how difficult is it to
try to decide what Aid to send in
well the needs are very clear we need
tense we need the eaters we need cookers
we need the blankets mattresses to
protect the people who are without help
but as you said we have a large
Warehouse in kazintep from which we
serve and we provide support in
Northwest Syria and we have only one
entry point into Theory so I'm very much
welcome the possibility of increasing
the number of Crossing points on
Thursday we send six tracks on Friday 14
tracks today we are Distributing the the
goods that we have pre-positioned inside
Norwest Syria we will go on sending
those tracks with those much needed
materials to protect people but let's be
honest we need to replenish them as soon
as possible because the needs are
Paramount and the humanitarian
catastrophe is terrifying as we we know
Syria has been going through a civil war
for for several years how confident can
you be when you send those trucks across
the border that they're actually going
to get to the people who need the help
the Secretary General of the United
Nations has made an appeal for a
ceasefire I hope that everybody
understands that we are confronted with
a major humanitarian crisis with human
suffering that is
personalized by millions of people so I
hope that everybody will have a last
drop of humanity stop fighting and
allowing humanitarian aids to be
channeled as much as we can to the
people that are in Lee in need because
as your peace previously said in
Northwest Syria there are four million
people who depend daily from
humanitarian assistance to subsist those
people now are Without Shelter they are
suffering the loss of their beloved ones
and we need to respond to them not just
from the material point of view but also
from the health and psychosocial point
of view I want to ask you about that
because that is an important Factor
isn't it we've been talking to people
over the last couple of days who are
working in hospitals in Syria who are
desperately in need of medical suppliers
of basic medical equipment in order in
order to be able to to keep the
survivors going to be able to treat the
survivors are you is your organization
and organization like yours able to also
include facilities for providing medical
support as well as the material sport
that you were talking about
absolutely we are working very close
with the World Health Organization in
setting up and deploying all the else
Personnel that we have on the ground but
the needs are Paramount let's be
absolutely clear the hospitals are
overcharged with tens of thousands of
injured people because of the earthquake
and so we need to create alternatives to
the hospitals to provide health support
to the people to the people in need and
we need medicines it is quite clear that
the medicines that we have had stock is
are not enough and we are making an
appeal to the donors to everyone in the
world who can provide us with medicines
to let us know so that we can Channel
them to the people in need of them we
really appreciate you being with us and
Al Jazeera sir thank you Antonio vitoni
vertolino thank you very much
thank you